[Aplausos]
mi nombre es nina significa fuego en
quichua
soy de madre kichwa de sarayaku y de
padre sueco
tengo un hijo que se llama te ama
yo
no soy un activista
soy una defensora yo soy lo que me
enseñó al hacerlo
y que quise
que una mujer de la amazonía les invite
a defender la amazonía
pero tu clase es mi forma de vida
yo crecía en la selva
crecí jugando entre los árboles en los
ríos buscando cangrejos debajo de las
piedras en el riachuelo
yo crecí comiendo maduro asado por las
mañanas a fuego abierto tomando baños en
la madrugada con mis abuelitos y
escuchando les a toda mi familia hablar
de los sueños del futuro y del pasado
mi abuelita fue mi mejor maestra ella me
enseñó la magia de la selva
ella me enseña los trucos de la selva
y los secretos de las canciones sagradas
yo viajaba con mi abuelita por la selva
por el río en la canoa
apenas tenía cinco años dejaba a mi mamá
a mi papá
cogía michigan
y me sentaba en la cama al lado de mi
abuela y vamos navegando por el río
apalancados 34 días
y va viendo las tortugas los peces
grandes los pájaros
escuchando a mi abuela contarme su
historia de cómo fue su infancia cuando
ella era pequeña que era muy distinta a
la mía
cuando caía en la noche
nos íbamos a una playa grande de arena
hermosa
mi abuelo ponía el anzuelo en el río y
después iba en busca de las hojas
grandes para hacer el ranchito para
dormir
mi abuelita ella cocinaba el plátano
y antes de que caiga la noche comíamos
pescado fresco con plátano asado
en la noche oscura solo podías ver las
estrellas
y podías escuchar las aves nocturnas y
las ranas cantar en coro la música de la
selva
y así crecí
con mis pies descalzos caminando sobre
la tierra húmeda de la selva
pero esa forma de vida se vio amenazada
cuando yo tenía 78 años
por las compañías petroleras
yo me acuerdo como si fuera el día de
ayer
cuando llegó un representante de la
compañía se hesse a mi comunidad
era alto flaco
calvo y pálido
toda la comunidad se había reunido en la
casa comunal
y él nos contaba todos los beneficios de
la explotación petrolera las mujeres le
decían en quichua andate
regresa a tu tierra déjanos en paz
no necesitamos la explotación petrolera
él nos ofreció 10.000 dólares
éramos 1000 personas en la comunidad
10 dólares por persona
hasta yo que era una niña pequeña
sabía que eso no era un buen trato
cuando esto no funcionó empezaron con
salud educación algo más llamativo
pero tampoco funcionó y yo sabía como
pequeña que eran promesas que no tenían
intenciones de cumplir
y que no los cumplirían
después de esa reunión yo sentía una ira
una ira aquí en mi vientre
una ira que solo una niña que está a
punto de ver su futuro en pedazos puede
sentir
en la plaza el vino a ofrecernos a los
niños
manzanas
y en ese tiempo el acceso a la ciudad
era tan difícil que muy pocas veces
comíamos manzanas
y yo tenía tanta ganas de comer esa
manzanita
pero
de toda esta ira que yo tenía me di la
media vuelta y salí corriendo
fue mi primer acto de resistencia
después de esto
nos fuimos a suecia con mi familia por
el trabajo de mi papá
después de un tiempito supe que ya las
compañías petroleras estaban ingresando
a mi comunidad
supe que mis primos
mis amigos estaban en la selva
defendiendo el territorio desde los
niños más chiquititos jóvenes hombres
mujeres y ancianos
supe que algunos habían sido golpeados
torturados amenazados de muerte
y
como una niña que amaba mi tierra y mi
familia ese tiempo en suecia fue
insoportable
porque nadie más entendía mi realidad
en suecia todo el mundo estaba bien pero
yo yo no podía dormir por las noches
y rezaba y pedía a la tierra que por
favor las compañías petroleras no
destruyan mi comunidad
esperaba todo el tiempo en las noticias
de sarayaku
supe que habían cortado uno de los
árboles más sagrados de nuestro
territorio
que habían sembrado 1.400 kilogramos de
pentolita
en nuestros terrenos lugares donde los
hombres hacen cacería
fue un tiempo muy difícil para mí
para mi familia pero empecé a entender
que yo podía contar esta realidad a
través de mi propia historia
aunque la gente no entendía
pero cuando yo lo contaba desde mi
historia desde mi perspectiva desde mi
vida la gente empezaba a escuchar a
entender y así comencé desde muy
pequeñita
a contar lo que estaba pasando
a escribir artículos
y empecé a salir en documentales en
vídeos recientemente
abrir mis cuentas de redes sociales
donde cuento mis historias
descubrí que esto de estar entre un
mundo y otro mundo era un poder enorme
y ese poder venía con una
responsabilidad
una responsabilidad que yo tomo muy en
serio
y aún más ahora que soy madre
a los 23 años tuve un hijo
pase casi todo el embarazo viajando de
una conferencia a otra conferencia
hablando sobre lo que sucedía en la
amazonía pero desde muy chiquitita yo ya
había decidido que yo quería tener hijos
en la selva así que a los nueve meses
regresé a sarayaku
[Música]
justo era el 31 de diciembre y yo me
estaba pintando la cara con we tube para
salir a celebrar el nuevo año con mi
familia y mi comunidad
pero esa noche celebré la llegada de una
nueva vida de mi hijo
te amo
junto a mi familia mi abuelita mi mamá
mi hermana
di a luz en la selva
siempre fue muy importante para mí
que mi hijo se conectará con la tierra
desde el nacimiento a través del cordón
umbilical tal como están conectados los
bebés cuando crecen dentro de la
experiencia de la madre
y fue en ese momento que
ni ná
se despertó en mí
mi fuego realmente porque si antes tenía
fuego
ahora tengo más tengo más paciencia más
dedicación y soy mucho más fuerte
y así empecé a trabajar con las mujeres
de la amazonía
de todas las nacionalidades de la
amazonía kichwa shuar achuar shiwiar
guaraní sápara
en el 2013
estas mujeres mientras yo estaba en
suecia estudiando
hicieron una marcha tal vez alguno de
ustedes se acuerdan
y llegaron marchando hasta la capital de
quito
pero el presidente en ese entonces no
les recibió
las mujeres hicieron tanta bulla en los
medios de comunicación que finalmente la
onceava ronda petrolera que en ese
entonces se estaba anunciando se tuvo
que postergar
qué pasó después de esa marcha
estas mujeres empezaron a recibir
amenazas empezaron a ser agredidas
perseguidas y públicamente humilladas
insultadas en medios de comunicación
ha pasado un tiempo
y la situación política del ecuador ha
cambiado un poquito
pareciera
que todo está tranquilo
pero al inicio de este año
mi tía patricia gualinga que es una
mujer defensora de la amazonía y muy
reconocida
fue atacada en su propia casa en el puyo
lanzaron piedras rompieron sus ventanas
de su dormitorio
y le gritaron
que la próxima vez le van a matar
las mujeres
amazónicas empezaron a organizarse
empezamos a organizarnos
hicimos una marcha en el puyo y luego un
congreso las mujeres vinieron desde lo
más profundo de la selva algunas en
canoa algunas caminando varios días con
bebés en brazos con bebés en la espalda
pero llegaron
hicimos un mandato que se llama el
mandato de las mujeres amazónicas
defensoras de la selva
ese mandato contiene 22 puntos
principalmente tratan exigen
la anulación de las concesiones
petroleras en nuestros territorios
amazónicos
y
tratan sobre las amenazas que están
recibiendo las mujeres actualmente que
son defensoras de estos territorios
y trata
sobre la violencia física y sexual que
existe en las comunidades y en los
territorios donde las compañías
petroleras y mineras están operando
porque esa es una realidad que las
mujeres están viviendo hoy
y llegamos a quito
y después de varios días finalmente los
recibió el presidente y entregamos del
mandato
nuevamente retornamos a nuestras
comunidades
y adivinen qué pasó
las mujeres una por una empezaron a
recibir amenazas
curiosamente de la misma forma
que patricia gualinga
recibiendo ataques en sus casas con
piedras de la medianoche
es gracias a estas mujeres guerreras
valientes que ponen sus vidas en riesgo
que todavía tenemos una amazonía viva
es gracias a ellas es gracias a los
pueblos indígenas que todavía tenemos
selva que todavía los niños pueden
correr por la selva que todavía hay
madres que pueden dar vida en la selva
tenemos que
cambiar nuestra forma de pensar
esta lucha no es sólo mía esta lucha no
es solamente de estas mujeres
y de estos pueblos
esta lucha es de todos nosotros
porque afectan todo el mundo
les afecta a ustedes también
y tenemos que empezar con el tiempo el
nombre de mi hijo
la transformación
el amor infinito
tenemos que transformar y cambiar
nuestra forma de pensar
esta lucha también es aquí
porque el mundo de ustedes este mundo
no puede existir
sin el mundo de los pueblos indígenas no
existe este mundo existe porque existe
la amazonía
y yo aquí
solamente soy un puente entre ellas
gracias
[Aplausos]